hello everybody I hope that are good I'm
going to try to keep this video nice and
short again today around 10 minutes
because uh I think that you guys prefer
it because you want to watch the video
quickly and then go into the chart and
see if you can catch the move see if you
agree and then trade accordingly of
course none of my videos are Financial
advice so you can only use them as as
Confluence to your chart basically just
as if I was another indicator this was
our projection from yesterday uh pretty
simple we had a a resistance you can see
all those
and then price kept getting rejected
from the area and uh dropping okay
that's a that's a very clear resistance
now when there is a clear resistance in
the chart or a clear support there is
always a stop- loss Zone okay a stop
loss zone is basically when the ret
Trader are placing their stop losses
okay so if in this white box we have a
very clear resistance what the retail
Trader is doing is basically any Trader
that is sorting here or here or here is
placing the stop losses above this white
box Above This resistance okay that's
what we came uh to the understanding
that this Orange Box was the stop loss
Sun also because it matched with the
order book uh if you watch yesterday
video you can see this more but the
order book yesterday was showing a lot
of orders are
52,000 and we could confirm that those
orders were stop losses okay because yes
stop losses are also limit orders that
show in the order book so pretty simple
analysis from there basically what we're
saying is that that it was likely to see
a stop hunt towards that zone basically
a move from the market maker to hit all
those stop losses before reversing price
and we go a reversal we claimed that 2%
reversal it was a possibility we didn't
get quite there only 1 to 6% well that
was quite a nice move all right so let
me remove this also what I find quite
interesting here is that look guys if
you notice this is the highest Spike
goes to
5243 and then the second Spike
it goes to
51,9 199 come on Mark maker you watching
my videos right you didn't want to give
us a second chance to load or shorts
there anyway uh quite interesting just
by $1 they then visit di again now price
has uh continue uh pushing price again
up from the from the point and if you
notice it's forming some kind of up
Trend uh I guess uh most of the retail
Traders are drawing this kind of uh up
Trend this this this trend line sorry
and uh basically when this happens we
have something quite similar okay we're
going to have the Ral Trader placing
their Longs for example here or here and
there is stop losses in this area Okay
so that looks like a face by the way you
guys are probably
noticing there is the face so anyway
when this happens then it's very likely
to see some kind of a fake out like this
okay uh this is what you have to be very
careful with okay you don't have to
short in me immediately as soon as we
lose this uh this trend line so be
careful with that because I imagine
there is going to be manipulation around
the support of this trend line so be
cautious with that now if you notice
guys and we only focus on this the high
basically the highest area that we are
now we can see something very similar to
what we saw yesterday okay and it's
basically that we have a very clear
resistance so look at that I just put my
line there and you can see how we got
rejected there once
twice three times okay that's a clear
resistance so why not why couldn't we
see something very similar to what we
saw yesterday okay give me a push Above
This level fall back below it and that's
when we go short looking for this trend
line okay uh very simple it's very
simple basically another type of a stop
H cuz we have here a very strong
resistance apparently so again any
retail tra that is looking uh for a move
down towards this trend line maybe maybe
the G is away maybe that right and the
get is away that move but if they are in
short anybody that has been in a short
in this area is going to place their
stop losses Above This Above This
resistance so why not why couldn't we
see the same as yesterday basically stop
hunt first drop again below this
resistance that is basically the signal
to go short because that is basically
telling you that that was a stop hunt
this move up and it was not an attempt
of a breakout but just basically to hit
the stop losses before dropping price
back down and then you can write this
move down to this trend line I mean how
much of this is a 1% move that for day
trading it's uh pretty good still to be
honest if you look at the chart go to
the Daily time frame it's been insane I
mean look how many big candles we've
seen in the last day go to the 4our time
frame the 4our time frame you're going
to notice more look at that that's a lot
of volatility guys and don't only count
the Big Green candles that of course
there are a lot of big green candles but
also count for example this week here
okay that's a big reaction this is
another big reaction of course this
scandle this red candle was a big move
okay that that basically was a candle
from 50,000 to 48,000 that's a 5% uh
move around 4% uh move okay so we're see
a lot of volatility in the chart in the
last uh in the last week literally look
we broke out from this
range last Thursday today's Thursday
okay that was literally one week ago and
look at all that volatility when we see
all of this volatility and I posted this
on Twitter yesterday in the last post on
Twitter I'm expecting a range soon
because price needs to to take a rest
okay uh it cannot be this volatile for
for much longer in my opinion okay so
expect that I don't know if it's going
to be a 52k remember that there is a big
resistance in higher time frame but why
not why couldn't we see a range forming
in this area for example here okay we
could see a range here taking place for
the next week 10 days why not it'll be
healthy guys okay uh because uh that it
basically telling you okay price is
cooling off then the EMAs are going to
catch up with the price and then once
you know it's catching up there will be
continuation but uh this is not very
sustainable this very big uh moves to
the upside without any rest uh so that's
what I meant with yesterday's Twitter
that some people perhaps didn't
understand what I mean uh that's what I
mean I think that price needs to to rest
again I don't know if it's going to be
here I don't know if this is the local
top or if it's going to be higher but
I'm waiting for a range give me a Range
okay then we'll trade the range and we
still make money there but in terms of
big
moves it's been quite crazy week don't
you think um that's what I think now
we're going to go again through the
weekly time frame because we've been
talking in the last few videos about uh
resistance Zone in the in the in the
chart that it could be quite interesting
and that we need to to test a support
and it's basically this area here okay
look if I make a box here they're going
to see this very clearly
we're entering a very strong resistance
Zone basically we go a rejection here
and another sell off here so why not
couldn't we get a sell off from this
point too the benefits again to you know
to retest these levels over here why not
it can happen but that is valid until
it's invalidated for that to be
invalidated this resistance to be
invalidated and the potential drop to be
invalidated I want to see price closing
above this uh Orange Box in the weekly
time frame all right and we still have 4
days for that so if we continue pushing
price up until Sunday and then on Sunday
we close the the quickly Candlestick
Above The Orange Box and next week we
don't lose the orang box so that's
basically two uh candlesticks closing
above the orang box then that's telling
me you know what this area is or now
okay there is not going to be a drop or
this shouldn't be so expect continuation
or all the way up to 60k because that's
the next resistance is it's basically
here the next resistance is that okay
and that is basically between 59,000 and
61,000 so 60k all right um that's what
I'm seeing at the moment for Bitcoin in
the higher time frame um I had a view
that it was uh more consolidation it was
a bit more of a b scenario around this
level cuz I was expecting uh something
like this I was expecting
in something like
this okay and as you can see like kind
of we're we're quite above that level it
should have happened here really at
50,000 and we're now 52,000 I mean now
it's to me more unlikely that I'm that I
was right okay so uh it's it's more
likely that this is invalidated of
course I'm going to keep an eye on the
on the resistance of
52,000 and it's a very
clear resistance support flip okay if we
manage to get this area support then of
course we can expect 60k but it'll be
quite healthy to consolidate around
these levels for for some time okay
that's what I that's what I think guys
so um that's pretty much everything okay
in terms of the trading you got an up
Trend that's why all the retail Traders
are keeping an eye on you have a
resistance here
give me well right now we're filling
this week okay look at that week it's
getting filled now if we manage to get a
push up I would expect the market maker
to spike price Above This resistance
Zone this yellow Mark then if we fall
again below that resistance that's what
I'll open a short quick short to this uh
potential support okay and then you have
to be careful at this support even if we
drop now cuz maybe I'm wrong and we drop
a straight away be careful again because
we could see some kind of fake out like
this okay because this is I imagine this
trend is why everybody is is looking at
okay and I I guess there are many Longs
placed in this trend line um if if we
break below it there is going to be a
lot of shorts opening and that's when we
could see a fake out to trap them and
spiking price up to heit their stop
losses okay so careful with that um
that's pretty much everything that I
want to say regarding uh the day trading
on high time frame resistances
so thank you guys so much for watching
and I'll see you
soon